Willkommen bei der Tourismus-Militärakademie
Ich bin Carl Marcus Reisner Ich bin der Leiter
der Forschungs- und
Entwicklungsabteilung der Akademie.
Heute werden wir uns die
ukrainischen Offensiven in Corazon
ansehen und harkip,
wie immer, wofür wir
vier Elemente verwenden möchten  Die Analyse
seiner Terrain Force Zeit und Informationen
und deckt
die Situation in Carousel und in Hakif ab. Beginnen
wir mit der Offensive in Castle
and Terrain,
wie Sie wissen, war die ukrainische Seite in der Lage
, erhebliche Kräfte auf der
Westbank des Tinapa-Flusses zu versammeln
die Situation dort  war, dass Russland
bereits zu Beginn des
Konflikts in der Lage war, das Westjordanland des Flusses zu erobern. Zu
Beginn der Vorbereitung
versuchte die ukrainische Seite, diese Elemente zu isolieren,
indem sie drei lebenswichtige
Brücken über die Verjüngung zerstörte,
zwei in der Nähe von Castle und eine weiter entfernt  im
Osten, wie Sie hier sehen können,
wenn Sie sich die zerstörten Brücken ansehen, wurden
diese Elemente, die westlich
des Pritchard zusammengesetzt
wurden, in gewisser Weise geformt  dass der Plan war
, einige Fixierungsangriffe im Norden
und im Süden durchzuführen und dann zu versuchen,
zwischen diese russischen
Elemente einzudringen und zwei Kessel zu bilden,
wenn wir uns die Streitkräfte ansehen, dann können wir
sehen, dass die Einheiten, die
von den eingesetzt wurden  Ukrainische Standorte wurden hauptsächlich
mit westlicher Militärausrüstung zusammengebaut
,
also haben wir t72 aus der Tschechischen Republik
und Polen oder sogar BMP-Infanterie-Kampffahrzeuge gesehen
, auf der anderen Seite haben wir auch
professionelle Themen der Art von Mist gesehen,
und natürlich die Heimer-Systeme, die das
Heimer-System war  Es ist
wichtig zu verstehen, dass die Brücken zerstört werden müssen. Es ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen,
dass Sie
hochmobile Einheiten auf der Grundlage sogenannter
technischer Mittel einsetzen können, die ihnen die
Möglichkeit geben, sehr schnell in das
Gelände
fremder
Systeme anzugreifen. Dann können wir sehen, dass die 16
Systeme das sind  Die besagten Lieferungen in die
Ukraine hatten erhebliche Auswirkungen, da
wir wissen, dass im Moment möglicherweise über 400
Ziele im gesamten von
Russland besetzten Gebiet zerstört wurden  Noch
mehr dieser Systeme wurden geliefert.
In unserem nächsten kurzen Video können Sie den
Schaden sehen, der durch den Einsatz eines
amerikanischen Hymer-Systems durch die ukrainischen
Erkenntnisse verursacht
wird  sehr offen und flach, daher war es
für sie sehr schwierig, die
Sammelplätze vor dem Angriff zu bilden.
Die Russen konnten
Aufklärung betreiben und die
ukrainischen Sammelplätze identifizieren, die dann
von Artillerie angegriffen wurden, wie Sie
hier auf diesem kleinen Bild sehen können,
wo Sie  kann die Auswirkungen entlang der
Lukenlinie im Bild
auch am Anfang sehen, als die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte die russische
Seite angriffen, wurden sie von russischen Artilleriesystemen angegriffen
, die der ukrainischen Seite schwere Verluste zufügten.
Das Ergebnis war, dass die beiden Befestigungsangriffe
im Norden und  im Süden konnten nur
einen kleinen Fuß in die russische Brücke fassen,
der zentrale Angriff in der Mitte war ebenfalls
problematisch  Angeführt durch das Problem des russischen
Artilleriefeuers war
die Situation so, dass in
den nächsten Tagen nach dem Beginn
das Problem darin bestand, dass die Russen
effektiv gegenangriffen und
hohe Verluste
in Schlüsselbereichen zufügten, wie Sie hier in
diesem Video
Pontonbrücke sehen können  die von der
Ukraine im Inneren über dem Englischen Fluss gebildet wurde,
um mehr Verstärkung auf die andere Seite zu bringen.
Jetzt werfen wir einen Blick auf die andere
Offensive in Hakif. Auch hier werden wir
einen Blick auf das Gelände werfen. Zuerst wurde
die Situation im Osten
von der dominiert  Während der andauernden Kämpfe in Donpass
versuchte die russische Seite, weiter
Richtung Westen anzugreifen. Es wurde sogar gesagt, dass der
Plan darin bestand, mit einem neuen Element, dem
sogenannten Schwertarmeekorps,
von Norden im Gebiet von Isium
Richtung Süden anzugreifen, um einen riesigen Kessel darüber zu bilden
Was wir wissen, ist, dass in den Wochen
vor der Offensive bedeutende Elemente
der ukrainischen Seite in der
Ära des Hakif auch hierher mit der gesamten
ukrainischen Reserve gebracht wurden  Inszeniert für einen möglichen
Angriff Richtung Osten Interaktion des
Oscar River Die Inszenierung der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte wurde streng geheim gehalten Es wurde
unter strengen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen durchgeführt
Lassen Sie uns einen Blick auf die Truppe werfen Auch hier können wir
sehen, dass die verwendete Ausrüstung
hauptsächlich von kam  Im Westen hatten wir also
T-72-Panzer aus der Tschechischen Republik und
Polen, wir hatten auch MR-113-Panzer aus den USA
oder den deutschen Panzer Pizza 2000 oder sogar
das mlrs-System, das ein System wie
das Hardware-System ist, aber auch hier müssen
wir wieder betonen  dass sie
viele hochmobile Einheiten, wie wir sie
hier sehen, mit dem Pushmaster ausgestattet benutzten
, um Ihnen eine Vorstellung von der Moral
der ukrainischen Truppen zu geben, möchten
wir Ihnen das nächste Video zeigen, das
kurz vor dem Angriff aufgenommen wurde und
das zeigt  die Ukraine im Inneren formiert
sich und singt die Nationalhymne
[Musik]
Auch hier müssen wir uns die
Waffensysteme ansehen, die verwendet wurden.
Es ist interessant zu sehen, dass es
signifikante Beweise gibt  Dass
man die sogenannten Excalibur-Granaten aufhetzen kann,
das sind also Munitionen, mit denen
man Ziele lokalisieren kann,
außerdem wurden Schadenssysteme verwendet, also
Raketen, die eigentlich gegen
feindliche Überfälle eingesetzt werden, in diesem Fall war
es die Hem-88  die gegen
russische Luftverteidigungssysteme eingesetzt wurde
und es der ukrainischen Seite ermöglichte, sich
zu formieren und weiter
Richtung Osten anzugreifen
[Musik]
Schauen wir uns nun die Zeit an,
wie Sie hier sehen können, führte die ukrainische
Seite die Operation sehr geschickt durch
die russischen standorte haben nicht sehr gut
ausgebildete einheiten im gebiet nördlich von isium stationiert,
man kann sie anstiften, in diesem gebiet
in die erste verteidigungslinie der
russischen seite einzudringen und weiter anzugreifen
sie taten es auf sehr clevere weise, weil
sie ihr handy benutzten  Einheiten,
sehr schnell anzugreifen und die
ukrainische Flagge in einigen Dörfern zu hissen
, was den Russen den Eindruck erweckte,
dass sie bereits eingeschlossen waren, und sie zogen
die Richtung zurück  Osten so
konnte die Ukraine innerhalb kürzester
Zeit angriffsbereit sein 50 Kilometer weiter
östlich
kommt nun das Problem denn eine Armee
die auf der Flucht ist ist kaum zu stoppen
wie man hier im nächsten Video
die Russen sehen kann  versuchen sie auf jeden fall
verstärkungen hereinzuholen im video
sehen sie
russische transporthubschrauber vom
typ mi-26 beim be- und entladen von schwerem gerät
diese hubschrauber
landeten östlich der stadt kupjansk und bildeten
eine verteidigungslinie entlang des flusses
oskill  Die einzige Linie, die in der Lage war,
der angreifenden Ukraine Einblick zu
gewähren, waren die Kernelemente der Eukinan-
Standorte, zwei mechanisierte Brigaden, eine
Airborne Assault Lubrication und die
Unterstützung von Territorialeinheiten und
anderen Brigaden, die diese Elemente
vom Breakthrough Point aus in
Richtung Osten und den Old School River angriffen
Die Aufgabe bestand darin, die betreffenden russischen
Streitkräfte
einzuhüllen. Auch hier bestand das Problem darin, dass, wenn Sie den Schwung einer rotierenden Armee nicht im Moment brechen  ntum wird dich brechen und
das ist, was mit den Russen passiert ist, das kannst
du sehr leicht sehen, weil eine Menge
schweres Gerät von den Russen
in der
verformten Tasche zurückgelassen wurde, die dann
von der ukrainischen Seite erbeutet wurde,
es war sogar diese Art von Vers, die es nicht
nur schaffte  die Ukrainer
bis zum Oskill-Fluss vordringen, aber auch
weiter in Richtung Süden und Ision und
Richtung Norden angreifen, und es wird sogar gesagt, dass
einige ukrainische Einheiten sich bereits
der russisch-ukrainischen Grenze nähern.
Diese Brücke gibt Ihnen ein Beispiel für
die Situation, die nahe war  In Panik
sieht man eine zerstörte Brücke bei
Kupjansk und man sieht russische Elemente, die
versuchen, den Fluss nach Osten zu überqueren
, um hinter die neue Verteidigungslinie entlang
des Osco-Flusses zu gelangen.
Die Frage ist nun, was das
Ergebnis sein könnte, und deshalb möchte ich
gehen  ein bisschen zurück in die Geschichte und um
Ihnen einige mögliche Beispiele zu geben, wie sich die
Situation entwickeln wird.
Ein gutes Beispiel ist die Situation in der
Normandie im Jahr 1944  Operation Cobra
wurde von den Alliierten durchgeführt, um aus
dem Brückenkopf der Normandie auszubrechen und
in die Tiefen des französischen Landes
anzugreifen. Zwei Panzerdivisionen führten diesen Angriff durch, der dann schließlich dazu führte,
dass die Deutschen
in The Cauldron of Ali in The eingeschlossen wurden
Folatkessel Sie mussten die
gesamte Ausrüstung zurücklassen und versuchten nur, mit
Lebensmitteln nach Osten zu fliehen, was tatsächlich
zum vollständigen Zusammenbruch der deutschen
Streitkräfte in Frankreich führte
Willen der deutschen Streitkräfte und
die Deutschen sie nicht aufhalten konnten,
bis sie bereits die deutsche Grenze erreichten
, könnte es auch sein, dass die
Situation wie in den Ardennen im Jahr 1944 sein wird, weil es, wie
wir wissen, einen sehr starken
Angriff der gab  Deutsche Seite im Dezember Richtung
Westen, die dann später nach einer
Schockbewegung von den Alliierten eingeschlossen und gebrochen wurde
, könnte auch möglich sein, dass dies
Auswirkungen hat  Der Rückzug ist so
bedeutend, dass es sein könnte, dass
wir in Russland so etwas wie den Oktober 1917
erleben werden, was bedeutet, dass die Gesellschaft
mit der Führung bricht, aber
im Moment haben wir keine klaren Indikatoren
dafür,
lassen Sie uns einen Blick auf die Strömung werfen
Wie Sie sehen können, ist Luhansk und die Krim zu
100 unter Kontrolle der Russen. Die
Russen haben auch bedeutende
Teile von Corazon besetzt.
Diese Zahl hat sich aufgrund der Offensive unter Kontrolle ein wenig verringert. Die
gleiche Situation ist Oberrussland und
natürlich in Hakif in Hakif  oder plus die
Situation, die sich zugunsten der
ukrainischen Seite entwickelt hat, die ukrainische Seite war in der
Lage, eine beträchtliche Menge des Hakif-Territoriums zu befreien,
wenn wir uns die gesamte Karte der
Ukraine ansehen, die Sie im Vergleich zum Rest des von
Russland besetzten Gebiets sehen
können  der osten von khakif ist in der tat
bedeutsam.
werfen wir nun einen blick auf die letzten
monate und versuchen wir, bestimmte phasen zu identifizieren,
denn sehr wahrscheinlich befinden wir uns jetzt in
einer  Phase 3
Situation Phase eins war der Angriff und die
beste Reise russischer Truppen aus Kiew
die sogenannte Schlacht um
Kiew Phase zwei war, dass die Russen
wieder die Initiative ergriffen und versuchten,
das Donbassy-Gebiet anzugreifen, was
schließlich zur Kesselschlacht von führte  luciusansk
jetzt sieht es so aus, dass wir uns in einer neuen
Phase in Phase 3 befinden, die durch
den offensiven Einfall gekennzeichnet ist, der für
die Bewegung nicht so erfolgreich war, und
natürlich die Offensive in Hakif, die
einen erheblichen Einfluss auf die
Befreiung des Terrains Ost hatte  von hakif
auf diesen beiden bildern sehen sie die
erfolgreichen ukrainischen soldaten im
südosten von hakif
die nächsten wochen und monate
werden entscheidend sein
es hängt von der situation auf dem schlachtfeld ab
und davon, wie
die ukraine den erfolg der hakif-
operation nutzen kann
Das schließt eine kurze Zusammenfassung für heute ab.
Sie fragen sich vielleicht, warum wir
in den letzten Wochen nicht mehr Videos produziert haben
, weil ich das Kommando über die
Ehrengarde in Vi übernommen habe
enna the honor guard ist eine bataillonsgroße
Einheit des österreichischen Bundesheeres, die
man leicht an der roten Baskenmütze
und dem Motto Hunter and Duty erkennen kann.
Es ist mein Wille, in naher Zukunft weitere Videos zu produzieren,
aber das Kommando über
die Karteneinheit wird übernommen  In meiner vollen
Verantwortung
möchte ich Danke sagen und bis
zum nächsten Mal